c'est une journée historique pour un à
maria gordon et sa famille cette
survivante de l'holocauste ne
s'attendait pas à recevoir des excuses
près de 80 ans ont passé depuis que
cette petite fille de 4 ans fuyait
l'allemagne nazie avec sa famille à bord
du ms saint louis avec plus de 900
autres juifs
elle se sauvait des persécutions
quelques jours avant le début de la
deuxième guerre mondiale il avait
investi toutes leurs économies dans ce
voyage
l'espoir d'une vie nouvelle en amérique
et en europe
cet espoir a toutefois été réduit en
miettes cuba les états unis puis le
canada leur ont refusé l'asile forçant
le bateau à retourner en europe
anna-maria gordon se souvient très bien
qu'elle et sa famille ont été placés en
quarantaine en hollande on fait la
guerre et les camps de concentration
allemands la hante encore nous avons
miraculeusement survécu racontent elles
mais quelques 250 passagers du msm louis
n'ont pas eu cette chance et sont morts
lors de l'holocauste
le premier ministre justin trudeau s'est
officiellement excusé
des excuses qui selon lui aurait dû être
fait plus tôt
nous devrions avoir honte de l'histoire
du saint louis et du mauvais traitements
qui ont suivi les juifs avant pendant et
après la seconde guerre mondiale le
canada n'est pas un pays très ouvert à
la diversité dans les années 30
cet historien craint que l'histoire se
répète on voit que l'antisémitisme aussi
pas en fait disparu
de l'esprit des gens il ya encore des
attentes hors extrêmement pénible lourd
et cruel donc on n'apprend pas vite et
pour beaucoup c'est aussi ce que croit
anna-maria gordini
elle craint les mouvements d'extrême
droite
la montée du racisme et de
l'antisémitisme il faut se souvenir
on n'a pas le droit d'oublier dit elle
il suffit de vincent choisi radio canada
ottawa